chapter 10. Beyond
um and so I feel before when we wrote
Beyond and it still applies
um Beyond represented a space that we
really couldn't help you with basically
Beyond is what is when you realize your
eye and we can't really tell you what
that is because you are you yes but what
we can do is tell you you know what it
is for us
um and beyond for us is sitting in the
seat of awareness so now that we've gone
through nine chapters of helping you or
helping out the house to understand
what is I let's break it down why who
what when where why now we sit in that
understanding and we live we don't need
to constantly tend to this understanding
because it's tedious you have you you
always are the understanding you you can
access it consciously that's enough so
that's your anchor and now it's just
time to live you don't have to always
remember that you are aware
you are
yeah
um
something sad man yeah ah anything you
want to chime in on that we talked about
it earlier it's like the front and back
of your hand it's like that that line of
the Shadow and the light that sweet spot
and it really is that is it's that and
it's that that middle way that middle
path that like the total
um Love For What is the total
um the total morphing towards the star
of just serving Earth Awakening yeah
um and it's just it's effortless that's
what was you know woo way it's the
effortless action it's the Flow full
yeah totally Flow full yeah and
and
I love that you sit in the awareness you
sit in the awareness that you know that
it's this entangled
superposition if you will of both
ignorance and forgetting and neither uh
of both ignorance and remembering or
forgetting and remembering or ignorance
and knowledge it's the this and that or
the neither this nor that yes and that's
that crazy paradoxical superposition
thing that is ultimately you just
transcend even that and this is this
beyondness that we don't know how to
talk about we talk about it how we
understand it and for you it's going to
show up some new cool way and it might
taste a little bit like kind of being in
the middle of a doorway like you're kind
of like you know you're you're in the
doorway of the front door of your house
and like one foot's in the house and one
foot's outside the house and you're in
the doorway and it's like is this guy in
the house or out of the house and the
answer to the question is obsoleting the
question
oh
man yeah I'm done man I can't I can't
there's nothing I can say after that bro
like the question is not obsolete so
there's no more questions I can't even
answer anything
that was great though man what is I the
end of what is I is obsoleting the
question damn
damn
mind you again we didn't have that
understanding when we wrote the book we
didn't get to the end like oh yeah
because we probably would have wrote it
wrote it but now that we're doing this
course continuing to be investigators
ourselves yes we could come to even
grander understandings about our own
work exactly man and this is what's
going to show up in our continued
Foundation yeah as we keep doing this
yes yes
man that's so good because when you
obsolete you know and you obsolete the
question that's also the obsoleting of
skyra and Atlas right that's the point
yeah that's the point yeah yeah
I love that man it's so good because
then that's the obsoleting of the guru
that's the obsolete you know the
greatest Traditions man they the
greatest ones the and the greatest
Mystics
the greatest ones that know what they
say is that when the student is ready
the teacher appears and when the student
fully knows Is Anchored In I the teacher
disappears right right
yeah yeah
and then it becomes a play and then
becomes co-creating like then you guys
reach out and you're like hey I'm I like
now we can just create together yeah and
we don't have to go through that process
we're both I let's get it let's get it
let's get it
what are we creating right yeah what are
we creating together and then we go to
Roscoe's and we watch the office yes yes
yes
exactly yes yeah because that's the
that's full non-duality yes because now
watching the office is equivalent to
reading what is I
yep yo
man no more Duality it's so perfect man
it just is yep
and you do what you enjoy
yeah and another part of Beyond was
going beyond the map itself because the
map is not the territory the territory
is Limitless and ineffable yes and so a
map is like our best approximate
conceptual framework to help
catalyze Awakening and so you use the
map to obsolete the map
yes and then make better maps and then
obsolete those exactly and we're about
creating not being stagnant yeah you
know not hanging on to Old energies or
old ways of being or navigating yes yeah
if you took a boat you know next time
take a car or a submarine or
some like but just do something
different right and this is currently
being seen in the uh Earth's shift out
of the centralized infrastructures to
more decentralized infrastructures very
bio mimicking mycelium right right
absolutely and and mimicking the
internet yes right and so this is now
what the decentralization revolution is
really excited about it's it's it's
really much it's really much our nature
it's so deeply our nature and so we'll
find in a sense we'll find many patterns
across these Maps we'll make better Maps
ultimately we're obsoleting the maps
when we know and then we create Dance
Play I mean it's Pure Freedom it's pure
creativity yeah it's it's Indescribable
it's ineffable ineffable ineffable yeah
yeah and that's so beautiful because man
when when you really like relax at okay
it's ineffable yeah and and then you
could kind of like yeah just relax you
could relax try it out and yeah and then
you don't have to keep seeking you don't
have to keep looking you don't have to
keep trying to describe yourself anymore
yeah you don't have to keep trying to
describe yourself yeah
and then you can just be
[Laughter]
[Music]
you can just be man there's no uh
it's no ego to uphold
you know
no identity to uphold because that
gets heavy
you know you want to be light as a
feather like mod says you want to be
light as a feather and
because you're coming from I you're no
longer trying to get
other costumes
to see you a certain way yeah and so
then you your choice your attention is
no longer focused on trying to get other
selves and their acceptance yeah to get
acceptance or validation or whatever
which is quite frankly a waste of time
such a waste of time you're wasting time
time is everything your moment is
everything the amount of time or the
amount of moments that you can spend and
experience is everything and you don't
want to waste it on moments and
experience that you actually wouldn't
consciously want to do
you know so yeah time you know it just
don't waste your time being an illusion
when you want when you want to actually
be an awareness that's what I mean
exactly if you choose to be an illusion
then it's not a waste of time it's what
you're choosing to do but if you're
wanting something but you're choosing
something else you know this is what the
book is for this it just kind of anchor
you back to reroute you back to let you
know that you are the one that is
Sovereign and you have the power of
choice and the Power of Choice is
everything
forever in the doorway
yeah we have to write that one down
yeah that was a good one that's end of
chapter 10.
all right well we are
at the end of the course yes we are I
really thank everyone for being here and
spending this time with us
you know
um you could have been anywhere in the
world listening to all kinds of stuff
out here but you're here with us and we
appreciate that
there are some last words of wisdom you
want to Grant because
you said a lot here so the appreciation
that guy was just communicating is
thank you thank you so much thank you
for caring thank you for caring enough
to know yourself to to explore the book
to explore the course to explore
yourself to explore the innermost
Kingdom
thank you for that and thank you for
thank you for then sharing that with
your friends and your families your
career yeah
thank you for
sharing your realizations and then also
sharing this book in this course
because these types of distillations if
they really create that shift in you
share it it's one of the most
streamlined ways that we can ignite
Awakening and
on Earth yeah
um I agree yeah and so we'll have all
the information for you
um
in in this course that you need all the
links that are needed
um
and to be free
I just want to add that I I want to
confidently say I feel that we're we're
giving you the tools for freedom and I'm
just going to confidently say that if
you take the tools and you're not you
don't feel free after them okay you know
write me a message but you know but I
feel if embraced open-heartedly and with
an open mind
an open spirit
you won't have to look any further
oh so good man yes the tools for freedom
you wouldn't want to look any further
yeah yeah
good job my brother appreciate you man
this was beautiful absolutely
and we're out
[Music]